y attendent c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
stosur pango un petit jeu romain maison
comme on peut le voir de par ses
graphismes et cette musique finalement
toute gentille c'est parti nous gars
vous allez voir c'est un jeu qui peut
être moi des gens lemay en difficile pas
facile parce qu'on est des guerriers
finalement allé comme on voulait voir
naître aucun engin pour sauter plus tôt
et voilà on peut sauter plus ou moins
haut j'ai su que les règles en chinois
jockey moi ça me semble un bon programme
on peut aussi voilà à tomber dans nos
échos et perdre le but c'est d'atteindre
le faisceau jaune labrecque et
finalement la sortie du niveau et qu'en
latin on a gagné voilà ce qui est une
bonne chose mais sur ce schéma yahia
embrouille ya des raquettes qui veut
nous racketter t'as vu pour les contres
on a vu sur rfo pas sur un jeune
attention un pistolet vraiment un
revolver quoi qui fait peur à tous
battus donc on va ligne aurait tout
simplement rhodia c'est un guet-apens
aux niveaux suivants aulas il ya plein
de niveaux enfin j'espère oh [ __ ] j'me
tire déjà dans les gamers immostat en
mode difficile j'ai qu'une vie oui j'ai
voulu regarder le boxeur la mémère
[ __ ] il me fait peur le contact on
switch en l'air tu as le move et il a
choisi l'âge des confettis et ses sa
annonce des fleurs [ __ ] autant pour
moi je sens que ça
ce jeu voilà un sujet peut s'avérer
hyper rageant il faut atteindre déjà ce
truc là haut
là j'ai trop peur qu'ils aient piégé on
ne peut pas au regard des regardez comme
il est fourbe l'ex une groupie [ __ ] a
tancé milliards attendus et c'est que le
niveau 2 voilà à 8 minutes pile tour où
on aime bien les choses rondins
notamment l'effet ans j'en ai marre de
vous nommer ce cade en bus ce point je
suis un peu plus de ces embuscades dans
tous les jeux bordel attendait à faire
d'aussi quoi ça c'est quoi
ah ok dicale quoi je crois un bonus tu
me fais agresser lb vas-y le jeu mignon
mais pas trop mignon quand même le kawaï
rageant le cas oui je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai fait ça là il y en a pour me cacher
ou ses chaussées chaussée je suis un peu
plus rock et l'arabe
attention aux piétons et ans tu m'auras
pas tu auras pas pape apporte en plus
chargé ainsi on fait tout à la fois non
sans fond l'idiot oui allait péter va
nous tirer dessus
non non la panique alors niveau tout
niveau de 4 si je puis dire pour qui se
prend cet homme déjà au pardon bon alors
voir moi j'aime pas le chalonnais
tempête quand je veux pas me faire du
mal à les emprunts - -2 fragmovie joplin
de et alors cette seringue logique
à mon avis elle permet de sauter plus
haut et oui voilà j'avais raison à
monsieur le fourbe et non on n'a plus le
bonus donc on va pas faire les cons on
va juste aller sur celle là oh là là
mais quel visage je vis et qu'elle
mangeait bien visé mais ça c'est
sacrément con regardez il attend il
attend sa balle en [ __ ] on aurait dit
je veux mais c'est aussi une minute 41
un petit à petit les guerriers là on est
à fond là ok au nom en c'est nul c'est
ce qu'on peut pas faire un culte à l on
se manque pas ou qu'est ce que je
voulais et là on n'attend pas et tu
ailles 360
c'était d'une beauté semitan ce jeu
comme c'est mignon tout plein c'est la
bonne humeur en boîte par an en
téléchargement plutôt adapté ce qui
évitera fait du gauche droite mais
sincèrement c'est fait la compétition
sur counter-strike de médecins soient
ces trucs aux campeurs vas-y vas-y tu
donnes ce genre aguets tu dis que c'est
le nouveau call of duty
du coup ils n'utilisent que des termes
de call of quoi personne de mon délire
non je serre les fesses mon gars
franchement tu pourrais mettre une
orange a trouvé de fès qui avec ses
attraits du jus d'orange excellente on
part toi j'ai quoi mais les temps ok on
va le défoncer d'ici les houppiers
garder le lit juste là attendait entre
les deux cailloux la nage à les désirs
non mais pendant la tartine de pain
grillé qui qui volent quoi je me fais
tuer non mais c'est honteux
et ouais alors pas une grille on fait
moins le malin sont maintenant lâcher de
la brioche c'est fini le pain tac
regardez rennes revenir le real et venir
ces petites [ __ ] la riaa ils font le
tour ils se croient en formule 1 non non
non non non je suis marteau et je vais
m'énerver je vais montrer mes biceps
mais non mais non briochine tu là allez
allez avec les petites et argovie du cas
tu ne peux qu être de bonne humeur à on
va manger un bon petit sandwich bio
après il y aura la forme casse toi car
toi [ __ ] on va se taper la brioche aux
plats dans tous qu attendait ce bonus là
c'est pour tirer plus vite je crois
qu'on aura les bras
je suis vous êtes en train de rire là
comme un [ __ ] comme quelqu'un qui a
pas de coeur ok on prend ce but je sais
pas c'est quoi mais je crois que ça me
fait tirer un autre à nos questions en
automate ya petit couvent est deuxième
et l'oif et n'ont rien n'est quoi lâcher
bordeaux il ya un truc qui me tire
dessus celui-ci lui ce petit ton cul les
tuent d'autres vos de ses deux faces à
ma vie rulut eux alors nous sommes donc
de retour sur ce magnifique que jai ho
là là que je l'appris seeded on voit la
tâche est sur la pente du jeu bordel de
merde
pardon monsieur après j'ai appris de
vous quitter déjà et sont dans l'eau un
oui j'adore cette musique là elle
réchauffe les coeurs
elle réchauffe les layton dont elle
réchauffe ou l'amour elle réchauffe le
même ton plat marie que tu manges aux
médias quand tu rentres des cours
regardez le regarder le regard j'ai peur
dans un jeu comme ça c'est comme s'ils
avaient peur de voir des bouts plus tard
et will be ok mais c'est le touch
ricains pour avancer j'appuie sur w vous
vous savez très bien les gens qui
s'écaille a cédé 2 à quel point c'est
chiant je vais toujours d'amérique ya
martin mon problème un téléphone bon le
fond lui lui au regard des rebels maps
et enraye a rien pas de favori c'est bon
ok on a analysé la baraque ayouba tant
qu'à faire rakkas toi allez tiens je
tiens dans l'arcade ou à la remorque de
stress on peut ni quel jeu donc à temps
j'appuie surgit chez pas pourquoi
et comme par hasard c'est la touche pour
recommencer le [ __ ] de niveau
attendons c'est quoi c'est plus même
niveau assez pour avancer niveau à
ça ne sert à rien ça
alors les enfants tout va bien se passer
lucas hochart ne t'en fais pas c'est
qu'un jeu c'est dans la tête
allez mon poulain un message comme coach
et moi même quand la tristesse fait
attention à l'embuscade
elle peut être partout allez mon poulain
t'es qu'une merde allez allez petit con
allez je t'ai vu henry vais t'emmener au
hockey volley tennis jaca moi c'était le
but j'ai senti ces petits poèmes
carissimo la revoilà on va pas se mentir
on y avait une semi sextape est ici bon
allez on avance dans le jeu progresse et
ruelles où et comment il est fou cachée
d'air son [ __ ] de cailloux il innove
non un petit ressort qui m'a empêché de
mener à bien mon enquête dans le trou
mais c'est pourri pour la la la la la la
la mais non mais non mais je fais tout
créé dans cette vidéo mais regardez
comment c'est énervant tout est mignon
ya tout pour ça pourrait que pas a dit
voilà comment on pourrait se trouver
dans cet endroit que ses cuvées fait
affaire daewoo nos avec eux et au lieu
de ça on est là on se bat contre on se
fait chier on meurt on meurt on meurt ou
elle s'écoule
ouais je m'amuse mais je me souviens
dans la loue non non non je veux pas
courir contre lui tu attaques du ciel
moi je suis tant qu'on voulait faire du
pogo
monsieur retrouver affronter des
tartines de pain
pis cette vidéo c'est matt a craqué je
voulais quoi s'amuser à mon mignon plein
de couleurs et de joie et de bonheur
bouaida comme ça vous a plu si ces cas
n'hésitez pas et m'élève de comme
d'habitude pour le coup c'est un jeu
rageant mais qui change pas mal du reste
là c'est vraiment à base de ce qu'il
montre ton ce qu'il est on peut voir
effectivement que j'en ai pu toucher une
merde quoi ça vous regarde et on
s'attendrait attendant une prochaine
vidéo tient tout le monde portez vous
bien en pis